ぶー僕はあーんせいかパティ other その先
要望で勝てるようになると
あー感謝食べ
[音楽]
春忍と申します
港区三田で皮膚科を開業しています
赤者の湿疹アトピー性皮膚炎やけど馬場の普通の皮膚科の診療から私は特に美容皮膚科
ひや音叉を専門としたきれいなる診療しています
規制になることで女性てはとても元気になってき
インタの平均
ここからやる気が出たりとか気になることは本当に
敵喜びたい今日の額を良くしていくだと思っているのでみんなが幸せになることが
とても楽しくて
一生懸命やっています
日出ですもしも種類じゃあ今日はよろしくお願い致します
こと2つくらいがあってハイカーさんくらいが違いました
どういう治療したらへいなって感じことを通し代の方がどういったポとしていくとまぁ
今後の美容医療においていいかなっていうの2月かと思ってたんですね
始め雪はだったらやっぱり ip
言えるとかあって肌をキレイに剥製など者のです
やっ肌キレイな女性はいいですねえ牛尾とか
みーや袋とか頭からに比べても進めばいいと思う
ブービー
酸味はクラメンと母は志望者と化した道
脂肪移植等で僕とも売っ救命な公共シュルツの一つですよ
あっですや仕様はを
ほらもってくるまんですよ
木は主にそうです
太ももとかですかお尻とか薄着のうん
あとお肌をきれいにしていったりぶどう1個買ったギターんすよとかですね
武道黒リフトうわぁねーブローリフトですね
をこすったのかなってきますかねそうですねローリストはい
[音楽]
ブルーリフトしくれればねあと何度かハイドロキノンですか
あっあって美白になきゃですね a 今2弾する方も醍醐派だって言って
助けます僕やったことあるなれば軟膏とかクリームの程度なんで
フレッジの員とかってああああだけていくように座ったか
風ですよねー男性だったと言ったものはどうですか
僕子だ立つも本当に入ってるんですよあっ品でスター早のレーザーだったの
その前はニードル脱毛行ってたんですよ本当にお詳しいですね行っ痛み対策とか
やっぱりそう来ませんだされたんですか
いやもう気合でやりましたね生揚げするとケ峯札のトラブルなしなってやっぱりインド
に行った時はすごい腫れたり赤くなったんですよね
でしょうねぇ僕に方はうつるお仕事なんでちょっと気を使わなければと思いや日焼け中
もいいされています
一体だとあまり変化しないですかね
外0撮影があるんで一概にそうでもないんですか
ブーブー spr とかいいえのぽっちゃりパイパン
4ですねやっぱり僕50+++ぐらいかあああああああヌー普通に生きてんですけど
[音楽]
usaki おっちゃんヌードル
おいシャベルやほぼつつもしてないわ歳聞いたしいろいろこっちから病気になっちゃっ
て
なんだ日焼けしたくない時はもう外に出ないのがいいらしいです
小山日曜と申します
ファイナンシャルプランナーをやっています
[音楽]
ケンユウのアドバイザーなんですが例えば住宅投資
保険そういったひとつ方へ
前半の彼の間のバランスを見ながらそういうします
色々なジャンルがありすぎるがゆえに例えば双剣だけ考えたり住宅もんだったか
家計全体のバランスは崩れてしまうと思うんですが我々排卵車ブラウン7ヶ月
すべての腹経済の仕組みまで考えた総合的なアドバイスです
それを心を持っています
山中ね子供用が好きですねもしもしぃこんにちわよろしくお願いいたしますお願いし
ますよ握手に動画クリエイターやっており待たずに社長と申します
私は親も一応と申しますメンサ会員のファイナンシャルプランナーってことじゃなくて
メンサ会員の避難するプランナー僕も
ティザー
メンサ会員でしてくっついふぁい nars の方もオバマ詳しいのではい
何かこうお互いの共通点で会話ができればと思っておりましたそうですね楽しみです
はい今日はよろしくお願いします
ファイアー者膨らんだって守備範囲広いじゃないですか中田広いですね
安島さんどのあたりがとっているかありますけど
企業系の fp と独立系の fp がアーサーいますねぼく dots 風と独立系
の fp ですねなるほど私もそうなんです
一緒ですねあの2000万円問題たことしちゃったでしょ
ああ
a-ha ありましたねありますありましたあれどう思います
金融庁の報告書によると上を計算されたきっ
ハロー後30年間で約2000万円分のお金が不足しちゃいそうですよられて1000
枚で足りますかね派寄りになっている退職金の減少傾向もありますし
あとは僕もそうなんですけど働き方の多様化もまたあるのでどんどん勉強してるんで
ちょっとなかなか現実でいろいろな形のシミュレーション
いうのも難しそうなところがありますねまあでも最終共通としては結局の意見だけでは
大外から投資の力借りましょうということになると思うんですけど一さんはもし誰かに
通しのアドバイスをするとしたらどんなもんだい投資することをお勧め
松翁機会にまたて積み立てていく
積立投資信託ああ私の音投資信託一番いいなって思ってるんですけど
ここですはい本当ですよあのアクティブとインデックスだったらどっちがおすすめとか
自分のスタンスでありますアクティブとパッシブって言い方でもいいんですけど
パッシブまあでですね運用目標とされるベンチマーク
日経平均株価などに連動する運用成果を目指すタイプ
そうそうですよね一方アクティブウォッチン太郎抜いて運用キャブ電池パック上回る
運用成果を目指すタイプですぼくどっちかと言うとそう
パーシー部のほうが安定はせるような気がしてませんああなるほどあの橋部って事は何
をインデックスに使うかがすごく大事だと思うんですけどどのあたりがこうおすすめ
ですか色々あるんですけど逆に進めようなんですか
逆におすすめそこですね私の場合はあのあまり国を限定しするのやめましょうって言う
んですね日本のものとかアメリカのものとか言わないんで一番いうだから msci
ワールドインデックスとか服とか
いうことがこれから先あまり人気は上がらないっと
はい僕はそう踏んでます
させると思えばあの
大変インフレ率のことも考えていった方がいいと思うんですけどそうですね
fas どれぐらいで一つももう叶っている
インフレ率ですよね
この先の
ん
[音楽]
はい会佐藤打つ hiro と申しますはい
弁護士をしております
まあ弁護士にもいろいろな仕事があるんですけれども裁判でを裁判所に行ってみたり
part 1祝相談
いろいろあもう企業にアドバイス
そういうことをしていますまああの弁護士のもとに訪れる方
まあ必ず何かお悩みを持ってい
いうことだと思いますねまあできるだけ早くこれからやるべき事をマジ明確
ん
せていただいてねそれに向かって一緒に行くという姿勢を大事にしてい
が youtube
bar ユーチューバー限定だとじゃやっぱ肇社長さん
モースも c 難しい初めまして弾みさと申します初めまして佐藤王族今日はよろしく
お願い致しますよろしくお願いします私職業は8動画クリエイターやらせていただいて
おりますそう
ああああああして欲しいよねもう
ます
ブーブー結構法律に移管さてぃはいぜひともちょっとコーナー会話ができればいいなあ
こっちもよろしくお願いいたしましょうウードゥー結構多くは c うふふふーんっ
基本的なないよほぼずっとしておりますウードゥー
あのうをっ相続とかで重要な法律に書いてあったと思うんです
皇族ん方ではいせいで何かこれはっていう
皇族方の快晴ですよねまぁちょっとまあいろいろ思うとかあったんですけど僕第一
バーン
皆たのはまあトレド事故で手に約40年ぶりに変わりましたからね
そうですねまあオクなんかはまあ実はは遺言イゴン所がやり方がちょっと変わったのが
結構いいんじゃないか
けど患者さんの遺言で売ればいいんじゃないかなと思っ
って言うからモックの際すごい思ってますってやっぱりあの子 hits 正面による
いい梵鐘が保管可能になったのがすごいいいなと思いますあぁそうですねまあ慰問デー
はだいたい
公正証書でグーン書をつくってこと思う
そうですね
で今回はだから下手通称所で結構使いが住んでいます
ぞ遺言証拠からうっていうハイネットでね法務局の方のイゴン召喚
そうですねはい減俸保管も可能ですし画像データ化も可能となりましたねそう
まあ現行並行もうずっともう色々不安
昔たままでずっとそばになるみたいです
んだけどバイあのから輸入者前がの公正証書で猛暑や紅茶家立っています
その音はのイベントって
法務局で法務省に預かってもらうかの違いだと思うぞ
そう
まあ金に関してはもうケースバイケースですね頭痛する気ばケースはいいですよ
まぁ今までだから遺留分減殺請求
犬的な効果ですね
大丈夫ですが
共有になってそれが黄海海戦な利点は共有関係が発生しないでは金銭的な請求てー
みたいですね
その辺は自分的に同駅悪くなっ
もう一度聞いてもいいですねまぁ今まで大海龍減殺請求権た場合も交換について
まああの風の対象が不動産がよく同伴
ん
はからうためだ本当にわからんかったためはこれ馬鹿野一気ペディアの情報量ず短
なかったです全く湧かなかった
林も漆芸ば
[音楽]
me
me あった
入ってるけど今に入って歌っていただいたみなさまで surface をいただき
ました
文章世の中の専門家という職業は役立ちそうな感じですかね
ピピンダーに乗ってないことがあまりに多く木て専門家の方の知識量はまた一つ人が
違うなと思いましたじゃあありがとうございましたありがとうございましたーーー
ん
[音楽]
いっ